no vale y que lleva tres semanas en
huelga de hambre ha sido trasladado a un
hospital regional para convictos según
informa el departamento regional del
servicio penitenciario federal siempre
con el consentimiento del paciente se le
ha prescrito terapia vitamínica desde el
entorno del líder opositor dicen que su
vida pendía de un hilo y anuncian para
el miércoles la que se espera que sea
una de las protestas más grandes de la
historia moderna de rusia veremos el
poder de convocatoria mientras tanto la
justicia rusa prepara la ilegalización
del movimiento político de nava y
también de su fundación contra la
corrupción la llamada fbk de naval y sus
oficinas de campaña están ahora en el
punto de mira de las autoridades rusas
desde la oposición temen que al ser
etiquetados como extremistas se despeje
así el camino para abrir cientos de
casos criminales contra estas
organizaciones y contra sus integrantes